So I'm excited to introduce our guest,
Dr. Jharett Bryantt,
Jharett, are you there?
I'm sorry for the technical difficulties.
My internet connection has
been spotty, (chuckles)
Let's just call it that, Jharett-
- Good to see you too, Sal, how are you?
- I'm doing great.
It's been a little while since
we saw each other in Houston.
Oh man. Might've been a year
and a half, two years ago,
but good to see you.
- Yeah, no, it's a pleasure to be here.
Like I said, I want to shout you out.
Like I'm one of your biggest fans.
So I've been using Khan
Academy since forever.
I think you literally taught me calculus
when I had to take my
teacher certification exam
way back when
I had to refresh on some
of these difficult topics
and I always had Khan
Academy there to help me out.
So it's been huge,
and I kind of took that
with me to my work in HISV.
- Well, it's exciting you'd mentioned that
the first time we met
and I was kind of blown away that I guess
I am now so old that people who
have been using Khan Academy
are now Assistant Superintendents
of major school districts.
But I think you're also
unusually precocious
in your career, and you're-
but that's flattering.
And you know, that's the exact hope of why
I've always wanted to do Khan Academy,
and why I wanted to focus on education
because if you can empower other folks,
they then can they go on.
and empower others to
do incredible things,
and I think you're an
incredible example of that.
Houston ISD for those who don't know,
I believe it's the fourth largest
or third largest school
district in America.
It's one of the top five, I think
- Seventh largest in the country.
- Okay, I was close, seventh
largest in the country.
I'm curious, you know, and
there's a lot to talk about.
I want to talk about
post-secondary success
and some of the things
y'all been seeing there,
but given the fact that
we're continuing through
the COVID period,
and this has been incredibly hard on,
I could imagine you and your colleagues.
How have you all been dealing with it?
Take us through,
what's been going on for all
of y'all and what's been going
on through for the
district since last spring.
And how have you all navigated the crisis.
- Yeah, well, fortunately,
I work alongside thousands
of incredible colleagues,
tens of thousands of amazing
teachers our senior leadership
our superintendent our trustees.
And in the middle of a crisis,
we all rolled up our sleeves
and did whatever we could
for students.
So, and obviously we shut down the schools
in March and we were virtual
for quite a long time.
We transitioned back to
in-person learning, but you know,
going virtual in the middle
of the spring semester,
was really eye-opening
for me because you realize
how fragile some of the processes
are that exist out there
to get our students into higher education.
And that happens to be
my work in Houston ISD.
Is focusing on what can we
do to get students college
credit while in high school?
What can we do to ensure
that students received college counseling?
That's amazing, that's effective.
That'll take them to where they
want to be wherever that is.
And of course, when you go virtual,
that's all in jeopardy.
But I will say that the great thing
about working in Houston ISD
is that we're very forward-thinking.
We've been thinking about online learning
for a very long time,
even before my time in HRSD,
which has been about eight years.
All of our high school
students had laptops.
We had been talking about what they call
the flipped classroom or blended learning,
which is a fancy way to say,
you can use your laptop to study
for class before you even go to school.
We'd be talking about these
things for a very long time,
as you know, so we're very
huge fans of Khan Academy.
In fact,
we had a series of campaigns
over the last few years called
the You Khan Do It campaign
or your Khan Athlons,
because we really believe in
virtual learning and everything
that comes with it to
supplement what's going on
in the classroom.
So even though it was
challenging for everybody
in the country, I would
say that it was really
quite the experiment to kind
of use all these tools we've
been building for years and putting them
to the the real task,
which is making sure that
our students are ready
to move forward,
to go beyond and achieve
their dreams regardless
of any crisis.
- And, you mentioned you're kind of,
one of your focal areas is
preparedness for college.
What have you seen you?
I was listening to the radio this morning
and they're talking about studies around,
the number of kids who were
enrolling in college this year
is 20% lower than what we see
in normal years, and
it's disproportionately,
I believe the number for low income kids
or kids from historically
under-resourced groups
is actually at 30% lower
rates of college enrollment.
Are y'all seeing something similar
from the graduates of of Houston ISD?
- So we're looking at that data too,
those are nationwide trends
and there are a lot of reasons
for that more so than ever before.
We're hearing on the ground
that students are having
real thoughts about,
"Do I need to earn money
to support my family,
or do I go to school?
Do I go to a four year that's outside
of the very large state of Texas?
Or do I stay somewhere more local?"
Maybe go to an open enrollment college
that, ultimately will change
their entire life trajectory.
But we had a lot of bright
spots, even in the myths,
the COVID pandemic in March.
I support a very special
program called Emerge,
which focuses on our high
achieving low income students.
And we work with them to get
into highly selective schools.
And one of the things that
makes that program great
is that we invest in these students
and we send them all on an
out-of-state college tour.
And we had a cohort of
students that weren't able
to attend an out of state college tour.
We had a lot of students that
have a lot of anxiety around,
how are they going to
make it to the finish line
and get to these highly selective
schools that are far away.
And for that program, our
numbers were unchanged.
We had actually a higher
percentage of students enrolled at
highly selective universities
all over the country,
but that's because we
made strategic investments
into students that really needed
an extra layer of support,
but it doesn't always look
like that for other districts
and schools across the nation.
So we're feeling the pinch too,
but we're really trying
to roll up our sleeves
and figure out, well, what
can we do to change that?
Because we want students
to have all the options
that will help them achieve whatever
their life condition is,
whether it's two or four
year college or whatever
that may be.
- Yeah. And on both fronts,
kind of the COVID and the
getting ready for college front
post-secondary success side,
it looks like we have another six months
of weirdness. I think,
we're finally seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel
with hope around a vaccine.
How are you at the district
thinking about that?
What are the conversations
you're having both in terms of,
how do you keep kids learning?
How do you help fill in any gaps for kids
that might've been disengaged
during the pandemic?
And then how do you ensure
that y'all continue to
beat the national trend,
of making sure kids aren't dropping out,
and getting to college?
- Yeah. I mean,
it's a lot of hard work
and I'm just one person
that works in a giant
orchestra professionals
that are really thinking about
how can we make the most of time
if that time learning has to be virtual.
Right now we have some students
that are in-person learning.
We have some students
that are learning online,
and we're trying to make the best of it.
Obviously we're going to have weirdness
for a very long time,
but I think the other piece to
this is that school districts
don't operate in a vacuum.
We're also subject to a lot of policies
and this isn't just a Houston ISD thing.
This is a school districts
across the country thing
where a lot of districts are wondering,
well, how will I get funding
if it makes sense for us
to be virtual for longer?
Or how do I approach whether
or not I want my schools open
if our counties are saying
one thing and other folks
are saying a different thing?
So it's really a giant,
big logic tree to figure
out what we're going to do.
But I would say that us,
like many districts are really focused on,
well, how are we going to make sure
that our students are safe?
How are we going to make
sure that they're receiving
the best education possible?
And it's really enthralling
being around colleagues
that are willing to do whatever it takes,
whatever that looks like to make sure
that our students are learning,
they're engaged and they're receiving
a high quality education.
And I do want to give
a shout out for things
that we've been thinking
about for a really long time,
well, before this pandemic.
We've really seen the value
in personalized learning
to supplement what happens in a classroom.
So that's why we entered in a
partnership with Khan Academy
a couple of years ago,
we were the first district
in Texas to sign on
for such a partnership because
we really saw the beauty
in what a product like Khan can offer.
Not that I'm a Khan commercial,
but like I said, I was a
kid that used Khan Academy,
so I really believed in it,
and it's something that
I brought into my work,
and most of my contemporaries
don't have that background,
but you know, today what's neat is that
we give PSATs and SAT exams
for free to our students
during the school day.
So we have a ton of data
as to where kids are at.
We're able to use that data
to personalize their learning experience.
This is something that
we valued for years.
So, when it came to put
that to the ultimate test,
we still utilize tools like Khan,
and what's great about,
our formal partnership is
being able to look at the data
to see, okay, well, you know,
how many minutes are
students using the tool?
And what we saw and equivocally
is that students were using
the tool more than they ever had.
Even we did all these amazing things,
we had our Khan Athlons and
all those things I mentioned
for years, but this was
something that they needed,
and this was something that
we wanted to push on them too,
because like I said,
I was worried about how are
we going to get these students
to college credit that they were going for
and their advanced placement exams?
We have a lot of schools
offer associate's degrees
while in high school,
how are they going to be able
to finish up their coursework
to get that degree?
We have all these students that had all
these post-secondary ambitions
as a 16 or 17 year old.
And for all of that to be
kind of put on the whim
of something none of us have
control over, it's a lot,
but we're thankful that we have
incredible college counselors
out there on the field
that are helping think through
and not to mention advocate.
I think the advocacy to higher education
is another piece to this.
We can talk about the amazing
things going on in classrooms,
but systemic changes need to happen too,
and it reminds me a lot about when
I was leading similar work
during hurricane Harvey in Houston.
Another piece of this is
appealing to the universities
to make sure that they know all the bears
that especially low income students face
when they're thinking about
what's next after high school.
So they really need to meet us halfway
on a lot of different things,
and we did that.
So we did that, we have
the instruction piece,
and then we had our
digital tools that we use
when it made sense to use them
because we had been
investing in it for years.
So when that way, we were
very pressing our thinking.
- No, I mean, it makes a lot of sense.
I mean, just a couple-
I'm curious about Houston
ISD in particular.
We've been hearing nationwide
numbers about digital divide,
about even where the
digital divide is closed
there's still,
we've been hearing 5 to 10% of kids
that were just having trouble reaching.
What are those numbers
looking like in Houston?
What percentage of kids
have had trouble accessing,
digitally?
How did y'all address it?
And then even with that support,
what percentage of the district
are y'all having trouble engaging with?
- So I wouldn't have
specific numbers on that,
and we have incredible
professionals in our IT division
that really took the lead
on some of the logistics,
but I will say that it
was a high priority.
It was a top priority to ensure
that there wasn't a digital
divide in terms of devices.
There was a point during this
pandemic where every student
that requested device got a device,
and that's something that
we were able to leverage.
So that way, as instruction
needed to be digital,
we were able to do that.
So for that, we're really proud of,
and then, obviously the
philanthropic community
and the community in general,
wanted to do whatever it takes
to really fulfill this need
for the students in Houston,
and for those of you who
don't know in Houston ISD
eight out of 10 students at least qualify
for free reduced price of lunch,
and the number of students
that are going through economic troubles
certainly increased during this pandemic.
So, really you have 200
plus thousand students
that have more needs than
they've ever had before
when they were ready and
underserved communities.
So it was a beautiful thing
to see how many organizations,
public and private in the city
and other folks stepped in
to make sure that we address
those gaps as much as possible.
- That's super, super powerful.
I'm curious, you know, there's,
and I get this question a lot,
and I'm fascinated to know
your answers are kind of-
you're a practitioner.
There's obviously a lot
of negatives from COVID,
a lot of them are obvious,
and there's probably
some ones we'll discover.
Have there been some silver linings?
And do you think there's
going to be some long-term
implications of what we've just
gone through that are going
to last well beyond 2021, 2022, 2023?
- You know, I hope so.
I hope that something's changed.
I know that all of us want to
go back to January of 2020,
or December of 2019,
but I'm someone who really cares deeply
about urban education,
and let me tell you that things
weren't perfect back then either,
as it relates to education
for students nationwide.
I think if anything,
that this crisis really
unveiled a lot of inequity
and access to things and made
it worse for the students
that already got the
short end of the stick.
So I do hope that certain
things can change,
some of that falls on school districts,
other that falls on, the state.
I think that we could re-evaluate the way
that we provide funds to schools,
especially during crises.
I think we can think about the role
of curriculum, the ways that
we can finance technology
in a sustainable way.
I hope that there are
a lot of conversations
that just show that when
things like this happened,
we really need systemic level change.
And then there are some practical things
that I really do hope change too.
Now some students really struggled
in the digital learning environment,
but I do want to point out
something that I think was shared
on the show by another guest.
Some students really
thrived in this environment,
and maybe they didn't anticipate
that, or maybe they did,
but in some ways, being able
to learn in a virtual way,
really allowed students to achieve things
that maybe they wouldn't have otherwise.
So I think that it's incumbent
upon education officials
and administrators to think about, well,
how do we know the type
of learning modalities
that will help students achieve
at the highest levels that they can?
And how can we think about
adjusting our programming
to making sure that students have access
to that type of modality?
You know, I think back to
the one room classroom,
not that I was ever in
a one room classroom,
but I think a lot of practices
that we still use in education nationwide,
go back to that way of teaching.
I don't think that classrooms
across the nation look very
differently than they did
50 a hundred years ago.
And isn't this an amazing
time to think about
what classrooms could
look like moving forward.
There are all sorts of
little nitpicky things
that I could pick on,
but I'll give one concrete example
that I'm passionate about.
So just as an individual I'm
very passionate about access
to community college,
and one thing that always boggled my mind
was that community colleges
often put requirements
for students to take
courses at the college.
They need to score a
certain number on the test,
like an SAT or whatever that is,
otherwise they'll need to
go into remedial coursework.
And the problem with that is when you look
at open enrollment institutions
of higher education,
the graduation rates are abysmal.
Sometimes they're in the single digits,
so whatever the system is,
it's not working in some ways,
I think policies like
that can gatekeep students
from pursuing a degree
that may have nothing
to do with math or reading.
So isn't this an opportunity to say, "Hey,
how about we change
that and figure out ways
to get students taking courses
that excite them right now,
without that course right now."
And that's what happened during COVID,
a lot of community
colleges across the nation
weighed those requirements simply
because students couldn't
access those exams.
But I would be curious to know
what that data looks like.
And you may see more students thriving
in their degree programs than ever before.
And that's because we were
forced to do something
that we had been doing
just to do something,
and we're doing it
completely different now.
Things like that, I think
are all over the place,
the opportunities, right?
Not just in education, but in
industries across the field,
I think we're reevaluating
what remote learning,
and what remote working can look like.
Imagine if school
districts and organizations
really stopped thinking
about who's the best person
for the job close to our office.
How about who's the best person for a job
that lives in the entire United States,
especially for small districts
and small organizations.
I think that could be game changing.
So those are just a couple of examples.
I really hope something
can changed for the better
when it comes to our students
and underserved communities.
- The last point you made is actually-
I mean, all of those were
really interesting points.
That last point you made was fascinating
because I actually never
thought about that.
Obviously, a lot of-
we as Khan Academy is actually
a distributed organization.
We have a headquarters and
we're kind of thinking about
to what degree how that
will be afterwards,
but I hadn't fully
thought about that notion
that even school districts,
which you've used, a very local thing,
even those might be able to
tap talent at a national level
of which could be quite powerful.
And you know, some of
what you talked about,
community college requirements,
I agree with what you're saying.
It will be interesting to see the data
when they waive those requirements.
And also one of my pet projects
is trying to figure out
how we can get kids,
the credit for things like not
even just the remedial work,
but the college algebra
or that first English
language or writing course
before they graduate high school.
But that we could have a
whole conversation on that.
We're getting questions
incoming on social media
and anyone watching, feel
free to put your questions
in for Jharett. I will try to get
to as many of them as possible,
but we're getting a lot of
questions about people curious
about your career pathway.
I guess I alluded to,
it seems like you're on a rocket ship
in terms how quickly you're progressing.
The first question is from
Susanna Garcia Dominguez
from YouTube, who is a
regular on this show.
"Hello, Dr. Bryantt,
how did you know that you
wanted to go into administration
instead of being a classroom teacher?"
And I know you started
as a classroom teacher,
but tell us how that pathway works.
I think most people know
how to become a teacher.
Most people don't know how to become
an assistant superintendent.
- Yeah. I think that's a
really a great question
because here's the thing,
I was one of many people
that went to college thinking
that my only path to success
would be to be pre-med
or to think of these
very conventional things.
And I was going to do that.
I went to a place-
- My mother still thinks
my only path to success
is pre-med, but anyway,
sorry, I interrupted.
- No, it's fine.
But the thing is that I didn't
know that my job existed.
I didn't know that teaching existed.
I took a course in college
that changed my life,
it was called Solving the
American Education Crisis,
and it was about all these inequities
that happen in urban school systems
that I hadn't thought about.
That was my experience, I
thought schools were fine.
They're not fine.
And I felt really compelled
to go into a classroom
and to experience that firsthand.
And then I think the thing
that changed the game for me
was that I wasn't so
much thinking about being
in the classroom versus
not being in the classroom.
I was thinking about what gives me energy?
And I would say the turning point for me,
because I did have a lot of steps between
what I do right now, and when
I was a classroom teacher,
but the lesson I learned
remains exactly the same.
So I was transitioning
out of the classroom
and I thought that I'd go off to be
what they call management consultant,
basically put together
spreadsheets and PowerPoint decks
for a living,
but really expensive and really
important to some people.
But anyway, I met somebody
that changed my life
because he was founding an organization
that really targeted those
high achieving students
in underserved schools to help get them
to highly selective universities
like Stanford or Harvard
or wherever that is because
those schools full rides
to students who are low income.
So anyway, I chose to drop
everything that I was doing
to make that program work.
And I think what I learned from
that experience was you need
to figure out where you
get that energy from.
I never felt that energy again,
or at least as strongly as
when I spoke to the founder
of that organization about
that special program,
but that energy, that feeling of desire,
that feeling of wanting to
make a difference in this way,
I just had to pursue it.
And it ended up looking
different over the years,
I realized that it wasn't so much
that particular program
I was passionate about,
it was really speaking up
for the underdogs in society
and making sure they get their fair shake
and they get resources.
So then it looked like putting counselors
in all the high schools.
That looked like thinking
about how do we get
as many low-income students
as possible to pass
an advanced placement exam.
Then it looked like, you know, XYZ.
But the common denominator
is I stopped listening
to incredible people that I really admire
because there are still
people that tell me
I should be doing X and Y,
but I always follow my heart.
And I know that sounds trite,
but I was very lucky that
something spoke to my heart,
and for the first time I
stopped following my gut
and I just did it and it
could have totally failed,
(chuckles)
but it didn't.
I truly think that that's what
made the difference for me.
- And on the other side of that coin,
what are the things that
you think you're doing?
And I know this is a
hard question to answer,
but what do you think of
the things that you're doing
that have given you that success,
that have allowed you to be an effective,
not just educator, but
administrator as well,
and for people to recognize that?
- I think the number one thing is you have
to be around people that are willing
to take a chance on you.
Even if I were to consider
different roles in education
or whatever it is elsewhere,
some people aren't willing
to take a chance on somebody
that thinks about things unconventionally.
It goes back to what I mentioned before,
I'm probably one of the only
contemporaries in my building
that use Khan Academy as
a high school student,
obviously for obvious reasons.
But I've been very fortunate
that I've had mentors,
I've had an amazing boss
who really been willing
to take a chance on somebody
who maybe didn't have
the most conventional
background for something,
but they saw something, they saw a spark,
they saw potential and they're
willing to take a risk.
So that something that I think
made the difference for me
was that I did have
somebody who signed off
on me taking on this job.
I think I was 25 at the time.
And some people would say that's crazy.
I recently was-
I made the Forbes under 30 list
and I finally got some Twitter haters.
Like I felt like a mini
celebrity for like a minute.
And I saw some of the things
that were put out there
and it's like, wow.
But I had mentors that really saw beyond
what people will say on
Twitter and that sort of thing,
and they just really believe
in investing in somebody,
and I wasn't perfect,
and I had people that were
willing to do what it takes
to make me see things that
I didn't see in myself.
So, I value that,
I really aspire to be
that for somebody one day.
- Now, that's incredibly powerful,
and I think it's going to be
inspiring to a lot of people
who are watching, people of all ages.
And the time we have left and
maybe this kind of combines
both parts of our
conversation, your journey,
and also the journey
of education generally.
What are the things that
you're most worried about
right now, either in your own life
or in education or in your job?
And what are the things that
you're most hopeful about?
And any other advice you
have for those watching,
especially the young people out there.
- You know, I'll keep it real.
I feel I'm a little worried
that people are going
to really romanticize what
it was before this pandemic.
I think that we're all
really wanting things
to go back to normal,
and I just hope that we don't
over-correct and go back
to the things that
really started inequity.
Remember, inequity didn't
start with the pandemic,
it was already there,
and that's probably a theme that comes up
in a lot of different fields.
It really accelerated things
that we're already there.
So the flip side, the
positive thing about crises,
whatever that may look
like, is it's an opportunity
to put a shock in the system,
to reflect and to do things better.
So while I'm very concerned
that people are going
to want to go back to the
way that we did things,
including the things
that really didn't help
propel our underserved,
I am really excited about this idea
that we'll look at technology differently,
that we'll think about
education differently,
that we'll learn how to
operate school systems,
school funding, school
finance at state level,
even federal policy.
There are so many things
that I want to advocate for
that I don't think people
would have listened to
for two seconds had this pandemic
not put it on their radar
as an issue.
And I know we're running out of time,
but maybe next time I can talk about
those particular things.
So stay tuned, my friends.
- We look forward to that.
Well, Jharett, thanks for joining,
and I know there's a lot of work.
You have your work cut out at Houston ISD,
but it sounds like y'all
are doing better than most.
And I think we're going
to see a lot more from you
in the education world
doing really great things.
- Thank you Sal, it was
a pleasure to be on.
- Thanks for joining.
Well, everyone, hopefully you
enjoyed that conversation.
I always think we're
like 10 minutes into it
and I look at the clock and I'm like,
Oh wow, we're almost
out of time, (chuckles)
time flies when we're having fun.
But hopefully you enjoyed
that conversation with Dr. Bryantt,
and I am always blown away
that he actually used Khan
Academy in high school,
in college.
So, one good we're having impact,
but we're getting older than
some of us would like to admit.
(chuckles) But we'll see you all,
have everyone have a good
rest of your week and weekend,
and we'll see you next Tuesday.
We're going to have a
real good conversation.
Continuing the conversation about families
and their ability to
engage during the pandemic.
But I will see you then.